And so without more do, then we'll
turn to our topic of the morning,
which is about the first embodiment
of a rational scientific medicine,
which is rather an extraordinary one
because it lasts from the fifth century BC
down to the 19th century as a dominant,
not exclusive, but a dominant
medical scientific paradigm.
Now that was associated with,
uh,
this idea of the first
form of irrational secular,
naturalistic form of medicine with,
um,
ancient Greece in the fifth century and
in particular with the so called father
of medicine. And that's our figure,
whoops, who seems to have gone off. Ah,
there he is. Hippocrates, um,
who lived from about
four 60 to three 77 BC.
Now there's some debate about whether
he was one person or a school,
a group of people. There was, uh,
there is a corpus of hippocratic Craddick
writings that consists of about 60
works, perhaps by multiple
hands, but not issue,
won't really concern us.
We're concerned with Hippocrates as
either this composite or a single figure.
Uh, and with the various schools
that followed in his name.
Now the 60 works. Some of them
are very famous to you already.
You know about the hippocratic oath we'll
be talking about such other works on
as on the sacred disease on human nature,
epidemics on airs, waters, places,
and he also had a collection of aphorisms.
One would note the variety
of the hippocratic corpus.
It consists of a whole series
of things he invented. He,
they invented case histories
and they're included.
Their lecture notes,
their memory around a of
all sorts writings on every
form of medical practice at
the time, surgery, obstetrics,
diet, the environment,
therapeutics,
all of that.
It forms part of the hippocratic Corpus,
so enormous variety in terms of
what Hippocrates accomplished.
I'd like to make a contrast and that is
with the supernatural view of disease
and the first form we could think
of that and drawing our contrast,
the contrast to what
Hippocrates accomplished.
We can see it in terms of the breakthrough
from something that proceeded it and
went alongside it down to our own day.
And this would be first of all,
the supernatural view of disease that
epidemics and pestilence are divine
punishment sent by an angry
God for sin and disobedience.
You can see this and many parts of our
culture, it's embodied in the Bible.
For example,
in Genesis,
you know that Adam and eve lived happily
and enjoyed eternal life in the garden
of Eden until they committed the sin of
eating the forbidden tree of the fruit,
of knowledge, of good and
evil. And as a result,
this was original sin and they were
kicked out of the garden of Eden.
From then on, poor things
they had to work. Um,
they also became subject
to disease and to death.
They were in mortal until that time.
So we see in genesis the embodiment of
this idea that diseases are punishment of
sin.
This was also clear,
you can read further in the Bible and
the book of Exodus where you learn about
the bondage of the Israel lights in Egypt
and God asking through Moses and Aaron
for the Pharaoh to
release his chosen people.
But the Pharaoh's heart was hardened and
so the Egyptians were punished with the
series of terrible
plagues that are all in,
in exodus.
Another way of the embodiment
of this was in psalm 91.
And this is of particular importance
to us. And let's move to, um,
share this with you.
Um,
this is the text of a psalm 91.
This is particularly important because
it embodies the idea of plague and
pestilence as a punishment by God,
but also in terms of our
historical experience.
As you're reading Daniel Defoe,
you'll realize that it's psalm 91 that
was read out from the Christian churches
during times of epidemic.
This was the great plague Psalm.
It embodies hope and an interpretation
of what the experience of plague was all
a about. So let me read part
of it here. They'll show up,
not be afraid for the terror by night,
nor for the Arrow that flies by day,
nor for the pestilence
that Walketh in darkness,
nor for the destruction
that wastes at noonday.
1,000 shall fall at thy side
and 10,000 at thy right hand.
But it's shown not come Nivea only with
Thein eyes shall thou behold and see the
reward of the wicked because
thou hast made the Lord,
which is my refuge,
even the most high by habitation,
there shall no evil befall thee.
Neither shall any plague
come nigh thy dwelling.
So if you renounce sin,
the pestilence won't come near you.
Well,
let me turn also to another
embodiment and culture.
Our Western culture.
And this is the opening scene
of Homer's Iliad, which is,
you know,
is all about the Trojan war.
And it begins just before this scene with,
uh,
Achilles anger.
That is to say Achilles was the
greatest of the Greek warriors.
But the Greek King Agamemnon had
taken his concubine for his own.
And as a result in raged Achilles withdrew
from combat and soaked in his tent.
Now he had a friend who was
a priest of the god Apollo.
And this friend tried to intervene and
besieged Agamemnon to right the wrong and
return the woman.
But Agamemnon rebuffed Apollos priest,
or as we might say,
he dissed him.
And so what we have here is this
tremendous and terrifying scene at the
beginning of the Elliott.
So let me just quote from the
beginning then over and over,
the old man that is the priest prayed
as he walked in solitude to King Apollo,
hear me, Lord of the silver
bow bring to pass this wish.
I pray for,
let your hours make the Denay
ans pay for my tears shed.
So he spoken prayer and Phoebus Apollo
heard him and strode down along the
pinnacles of Olympus,
angered in his heart,
carrying across his shoulders,
the bow and the hooded quiver and the
shafts clasped on the soldier shoulders of
the God walking.
Angrily he came.
Ms. Knight comes down and knelt down
apart and opposite the ships and let go.
And Arrow terrible was the
clash from the bow of silver.
First he went after the mules and
the circling hounds then let go,
uh, tearing Arrow against the
men themselves and struck them.
The corpse fires burned everywhere
and did not stop burning.
So that was Apollo punishing the on behalf
of his priest or let me also mention
something example that's more
recent and closer to home. That is,
I want to talk for a minute about a Yalie.
And this is our friend here,
John Humphrey,
noise of the 19th century who
was at the Yale divinity school.
And he read the pieces we've just talked
about and thought about disease as a
punishment for sin and decided,
well, there was a remedy.
And so in all modesty,
he and a group of his friends decided
that they were going to renounce sin all
together and they called themselves the
perfectionists and they founded an ideal
community, first in Putney, Vermont,
and then an Oneida in New York state.
It's part of the history of American
Utopian communities in which they renounce
sin. And we're going to live together, uh,
and harmony and peace forever as a people.
And every morning began with a mutual
criticism in which they pointed out each
other's faults. This must
have been a lot of fun, uh,
in order that they not fall by the
wayside and lops once again into sin.
Well,
I'm sorry to tell you,
this was the 1840
[inaudible] by the 1890s,
the ideal community had become instead
of joint stock company and you still have
Oneida pottery and silverware,
and I'm very sorry to report that all of
the members of the community have been
buried.
Uh,
I don't know if that was because they
couldn't stick the pace or if the concept
was wrong from the
outset. In any case, uh,
this was an embodiment then of the idea
of disease as a punishment for sin.
But if we view this view of
pestilence as divine punishment,
it does at least imply
a log governed comms.
Mus Disease exists for
an intelligible reason,
and it implies a rational therapeutics,
which is repentance,
propitiation of God amendment of conduct,
and renewed obedience to the laws.
There's another variation
of a supernatural view,
which is more capricious.
And let's call that the
demonic theory of disease.
This pop stipulates that the
world is populated by powerful,
arbitrary and evil spirits who cause
disease through their Maniape influence.
These may be evil persons
such as witches or poisoners,
the disembodied spirits of the dead
super human beings or the devil himself.
We'll see this view throughout the course,
the idea that epidemic
diseases or diabolical plot,
not natural events.
There's some a colt secret crime
caused by the poisoning of witches or
scapegoats,
and this gives rise to witch hunts
to hunt down and punish the guilty.
We know this famously in the 17th
century and in our own country at Salem,
but the idea was clearly expressed in
Europe by Martin Luther who declared I
would have no pity on the witches.
I would burn the mall.
Alternatively,
that was a good therapeutic idea.
a person could be deemed to be inhabited
or possessed by an evil spirit,
and in that case to cure was to
cast out the devil through exorcism.
And this cosmology survives
in our own language.
When we talked today about someone acting
like someone possessed or out of his
mind and healers pursuing these sorts
of ideas would invoke magic or have
incantations.
They'd prescribed special concoctions,
chance, sacred rites and
spells, and in European history,
and relatively recent illustration of
that idea was the idea of the healing
power of the royal tach. Charles,
the second of England, for example,
administered this treatment in the
17th century to about 100,000 people.
So healers could do that.
They could also recommend magic practices,
offerings and sacrifices,
magic charms to ward off the evil spell
where they could recommend escaping by
taking flight or invoking the power of
a powerful ally as in the Christian cult
of saints that we'll be talking
about later. So if you hold that up,
those two views then of supernatural
interpretations of disease,
then you can understand the breakthrough
that was made in fifth century Greece.
This was in contrast to the supernatural,
divine and demonic theories.
And that's in contrast to them that we
can see the importance of a new idea,
the idea that disease instead,
as a naturalistic event that can
be understood by natural causes.
Examples of this new naturalistic secular
view abounded in the fifth century.
You can see it in through city ds and
his account of the Peloponnesian war,
the famous plague of Athens that may
have been typhus or more recently it was
thought to have been typhoid,
but in any case it was a natural event
and is described as such by through
cities with no reference to
the occult or the supernatural.
You can see it in Hippocrates discussion
on epidemics in which diseases epidemic
diseases are caused by a
corruption of the year.
But let me talk about this very famous
example and dramatic one of Hippocrates
on the sacred disease
by the sacred disease.
He meant epilepsy and it looks,
I guess if you wanted any disease that
looks like a possession by a demon,
it is epilepsy and Hippocrates wants to
tell us that this is not a supernatural
event or a possession.
He says instead something
extremely different. Uh,
what he tells us is that,
um,
it is thus with regard to
the disease called sacred,
it appears to me to be no wise,
more divine or sacred than other diseases,
but has a natural cause
like other afflictions,
men regard it's nature and cause as
divine from ignorance and wonder.
And this notion of its divinity is kept
up by their inability to comprehend it.
Neither truly do I count it as a worthy
opinion to hold that the body of man is
polluted by God,
the most impure by the most holy for war,
the body defiled,
it would be likely to be purified
and sanctified rather than polluted.
Those who first referred
this malady to the gods,
you appear to me to have been just such
persons as the conjurers mount banks and
charlatans are such persons.
Then using the divinity as a pretext
and screen for their own inability to
afford assistance have given
out that the disease is sacred.
This was a very major
breakthrough conceptually,
the beginning of the foundation
of a scientific medicine.
So therapeutics then got rid in
a naturalistic view of chance,
potion spells and sacrifices and exorcism,
appeasement of the gods.
The importance of this momentous step in
human consciousness was expressed by a
Yale professor of
epidemiology in the 1940s,
Charles Edward Winslow who wrote,
and let me quote a
sentence or two from him.
If disease is postulated as
caused by gods demons or demons,
scientific progress is impossible.
If it is attributed to
hypothetical humors,
the theory can be tested and improved.
The conception of natural causation
was the essential first step.
It marks incomparably the most epochal
advance in the intellectual history of
mankind. That perhaps is
putting it a little strongly,
but you certainly get the point now,
why perhaps was there a
rational scientific medicine
in fifth century Greece
here?
I think the main part of the answer has
to be imponderable factors such as the
inspiration of Hippocrates
himself and his associates.
But there were influences we
could point to as important,
the absence of a priestly bureaucracy
with the power to sanction heretics.
Decentralized city states the
legacy of Greek natural philosophy,
um,
the work of Plato and Aristotle in
particular a culture of individualism.
And I think we also need to
remember that hippocratic position,
physicians, although they were
known to treat the poor and slaves,
their care was not buying
large available to the masses.
The primary clientele
consisted of educated,
prosperous elites in ancient
Greece and ancient Rome.
And this was a medical
philosophy that suited them.
The educated doctor and the educated
patient spoke the same language and the
therapies that the physician proposed,
such as a special diet or rest were
remedies the wealthy could afford.
Now, we should say that hippocratic
medicine is still with us.
We can see it in the return
to holistic medicine.
We can see it also in the Muslim world in,
you can still be treated in new noni
medicine by a hippocratic style medicine.
And you can see it in certain popular
cultural precepts such as the one feed a
cold and starve a fever. Well,
if that's it's important,
let's look at its content.
What was the content then of this first
embodiment of scientific medicine?
And it was humorous realism.
Here,
let's talk about what that is.
The fundamental assumption was that
there's a correspondence between the
macrocosm of the universe and the
microcosm of the Individual Bondi.
Both are composed of the same materials,
subject to the same laws and disorder
can occur in one and be followed by
disease in the body.
Now according to Aristotle
and natural philosophy,
the macrocosm consisted
of four elements that you can see here.
They were
earth, water, air and fire.
And each of the elements is associated
with four qualities which they can be dry
and hot like fire or dry and cold
or cold and wet or wet and hall.
So the elements embody also four qualities
in different proportions of course.
And this went on over the centuries
and there were four seasons,
four wins later on for evangelists.
But the point for us is there was also
a microcosm and one can see the theory
expounded on human,
on human nature in which there
are four humors which are blocked,
bile, phlegm, phlegm,
black bile,
yellow bile and blood.
And each of those also,
um,
the body is composed of these and each
has qualities of as being wet and cold or
hot and dry.
Uh,
this also determines the balance
of these humors in the body.
The four temperaments, whether
you're a melancholic, flameouts,
cleric or sanguine,
those words survive in our culture
there for ages of men, for principle,
organs of the body, the spleen,
the brain, the liver and heart.
You'll see the importance of four.
And the system is axiomatic.
It's based on deductive
reasoning from first principles.
Central of course,
to all of it was the climate of Greece
with its seasonal patterns and it's
specific patient population.
Many were malarial victims with
the complications of pneumonia.
And Hippocrates indeed was the
world's first malaria. Ologist.
No health consisted what's
called you crazy, huh?
Which meant a balance or equal Librium
of the humors and therefore have the
qualities and variations are possible.
Uh,
we're up to a certain threshold and at
various times in your life or from one
person to another, the balance
among the four humors can change.
But once you cross a certain threshold
in variation that is one humor becomes
overly dominant or one humor is
lacking in sufficient supply.
That's an inbound.
Once that's dis crazier an
excess or deficiency of one
of the humors and that is
disease.
So we know what diseases,
then it's an imbalance of the humors.
So note that there is no single,
that is to say there aren't discrete
individual diseases as in modern medicine
that is diseases classified as typhoid,
cancer,
pneumonia and all the rest.
Disease instead was a holistic
phenomenon of Bondi equilibrium.
There was an esense only one disease.
Now what were the causes?
The causes were said to be what we
might call in monitoring jargon,
environmental insults that gay lung
later on was to codify as the six non
naturals,
the human body and constitution then
had contact with the air which might be
corrupted or my asthmatic
as it was called later. Uh,
motion or what we might call exercise
was the second not or it's lack
non-natural sleep or wakefulness excretion
or retention of whatever was ingested
and the passions of the soul.
These were the non naturals that
could tip the body into disease.
Now,
restoring health was based
in part on nature itself.
That is to say there's a teleology ology
of the body embodied in the phrase,
these matey cut treats not to die,
which is the healing power of nature
and the means to restore the body,
in other words,
strives to restore equilibrium through
[inaudible] or through the elimination of
excess humors.
When you sweat,
you sneeze or you vomit for all of that
is your body's attempt to get rid of the
humor that's making you
sick because of its excess.
So this led then to a
humoral therapeutics,
and let's talk about that.
The basis of medical strategy was that
the physician was the ally of nature and
of the body.
The body was trying to restore itself to
help to health and the physician would
join it and doing battle against disease.
He would read the signs to decipher the
underlying process would take a case
history would practice close observation,
taking the pulse,
listening to the body and
would examine the urine.
It's color, it's density. Ah,
he would smell it and taste it and see
whether it contained blood or was frothy
as all of those work
worrying prognostic signs.
It was a holistic treatment where you
didn't treat individual symptoms but the
whole constitution and it also had an
idea of the individual realism of the
patient.
Treatment should be tailored to
the constitution of the individual.
There are no disease entities because
disease is not a thing but a process.
So this was a medicine that was round.
They're indifferent to
diagnosis or classification.
What it stressed instead was the answer
to the patient's eternal question and I
going to be all right,
doc.
Prognosis was what really mattered
to the hippocratic physician.
The therapeutic principle was
that opposites treat opposites.
So if you have an excess of a dry
and cold humor like the block Boyle,
um,
if that's the humor that's
causing your illness,
then you would like to perhaps to give
the patient a food to ingest that would
be wet and hot and hot.
In this case.
Think of it and not simply as the touch
we think of it when we talk about spicy
food is being hot,
so all the elements that you have also
have qualities and so diet is very
important to this therapeutics,
so the tools available to the
physician then our first of all diet.
In some sense the hippocratic physicians
thought we are what we eat and all
foodstuffs had qualities,
hot, cold, moist,
dry to balance an opposite defect
or excess in the human body.
Exercise was also important.
A change of environment in modern
terms going to a spa or a sanatorium,
a moderation in the emotions.
Moderation in Saks and medication
was important because the,
they did practice hippocratic physicians,
internal medicine examples were to promote
evacuation by providing emetics sue
terrifics,
purgatives or diuretics and most uh,
important perhaps was a
primacy of Venus section,
by which I mean
bloodletting or phlebotomy,
that became the hallmark
of the Orthodox physician.
Medicine in other words,
was conceived as a process
of addition and subtraction,
adding what is wanting and
subtracting what is an excess.
Now you may have your
doubts about Venus section.
Let me just mention some of its
advantages in the eyes of hippocratic
physicians.
It was systematic like disease itself.
It's effects were immediate
and you could control them.
It was speedy.
It's limits were also self
evident to the experienced doctor.
Perhaps the patient fainted,
the pulse disappeared,
or the color of the blood altered.
There were how are for, of course,
contrary indications to bloodletting
old age and deficiency of blood.
The summer heat evacuation already
occurring by other means or extreme cold.
So the Lancet,
the instrument for a bloodletting,
uh, there we have real lancets, uh,
became the symbol of the orthodox
position down through the 19th century.
Now note that there is no
real humoral physiology,
no idea of the circulation of the blood.
The heart is not a pump,
but a furnace drawing air from the lungs,
heating it and distributing as
in it as innate heat in the body.
So this was the first embodiment
of scientific medicine.
I want to talk about an alteration
that it went through through the second
father of medicine.
And this is another Greek
physician who lived, however,
in ancient Rome and not is Galen.
And that's a picture now,
his personal,
he lived in the second century,
a d from one 30 to about two oh one with
his formative years being lived out in
Rome.
His personal qualities are important.
He was very different from Hippocrates.
Hippocrates was a great
observer and empiricists.
Galen instead prided himself above
wall on his knowledge of the texts of
Hippocrates.
He almost worshiped to pocker teas,
but regarded himself as the authorized
interpreter if it parked at it worse,
which he turned into a dogma.
Now in Rome,
Galen was physician to the gladiators.
His personal position, uh,
helps explain his influence.
He then became private doctor to the
emperor and he regarded himself as the
ideal physician,
philosopher and scientist.
He was a man of overweening
self confidence who had
nothing but withering scorn
for his opponents and colleagues
whom he called murderer's amateurs,
unversed in hippocratic
wisdom as he called them,
more ignorant than animals.
It was true also that Galen
had an encyclopedic knowledge,
and we can only understand his influence
if we remember that he was a man of
immense knowledge of all branches of
the medicine that existed at his time,
and only half of his
written works survive,
but they alone fill 12 volumes
of about a thousand pages each.
In other words,
he was extraordinary and his productivity,
and that too is important
on his influence. Now,
Galen had a view that was foreign to us
of the meaning of scientific progress.
To him,
Hippocrates was the permanent foundation
of medical science and the main tenants
of that science could never
be overturned or revised.
Instead.
There was no room in his thinking
for scientific revolutions.
The writings of Hippocrates were valid
forever that could only be completed and
perfected. And in fact, that
was gay. Lynn's view of himself,
he was the person who perfected
hippocratic ideas. So in fact,
further progress was probably
unnecessary and perhaps impossible.
So Galen became the authoritative
interpreter of Hippocrates.
So this is what we might call gala Newsom.
And then his hands.
Hippocrates became a cult figure,
an object of veneration,
enormous worship,
apoc Ortiz about whom so little
was known in his personal life,
was now endowed with all
manner of apocryphal virtues.
He was idealized as a model of wisdom,
courage,
temperance,
humanity and honesty.
Mythologies developed about his
religious piety, his heroism,
and his hard work.
There was a legend that he was descended
on his father's side from the God
Asclepius and on the
maternal side from Hercules.
He was said to be a great patriot
who saved Athens from the plague.
A man who scorned money and was perfectly
wise and perfectly just so he became
one of the greatest cultural figures of
antiquity and equivalent in a different
way of Socrates,
Plato and Aristotle.
Now,
probably some of you are wondering,
we've talked about humor,
realism,
and its advocates and you'll want to know,
well,
that's all very fine.
Did it work?
I'd like to say that humor
realism had a number of strengths.
It was a quantum leap from magical
thinking to naturalistic explanations of
disease.
It appealed because it was accessible to
educated layman contemporaries with an
education.
Understood everything that hippocratic
can galenic doctors said and prescribed.
It was consonant with
contemporary understandings.
We also need to know that hippocratic
and galenic physicians practice
therapeutic modesty.
They did not participate in surgery
except for example for setting bones,
Lansing abscesses and
practicing Vena section.
But then your internal cavities of
the body they knew were off limits.
It was based on observation.
They took case histories.
And we ought to remember in terms
of medical effectiveness that uh,
my wife for example,
who is a primary care physician,
says that about 75% of patients who
present themselves in a clinic have self
limiting illnesses or psychosomatic
ones and mostly need reassurance that
everything will be alright.
So the point about hippocratic medicine
was that experienced physicians
accustomed to seeing ill people
would be pretty good at prognosis and
reassurance.
They would refuse to treat cases they
regarded as hopeless and hopeless cases.
They also had a referral system
will refer to in a minute,
which was to temples.
I'll come back to that in just a second.
There were, however, a
number of weaknesses.
So hippocratic galenic medicine
had a number of powerful strengths.
It provided a lot in terms of reassurance
and prognosis and the answer to that
eternal question, will I be all
right doc? And the other question,
what can I do to help myself?
There were a number of weaknesses.
It was a closed system.
It was based on deductive reasoning and
came to be a bound up in the authority
of the ancients with
empiricism fading away.
And indeed in later centuries it
comes to be called library medicine.
It was anchored in a cult of personality,
the cult of Galen,
and through him of Hippocrates
and practice a cult of
antiquity with knowledge
almost becoming a form of revealed truth.
So gala,
Nazism involved authority and tradition
and elite medicine of university trained
physicians who were involved,
particularly in their training
and studying the classics.
So how do you train a physician?
You have them read Hippocrates and
Galen in the original languages.
Now, I don't want to say however,
that there were no challenges.
It's extraordinary to reflect that
humor realism as a dominant medical
philosophy persists into the 19th century.
But I don't want to think
that it was unchallenged.
We know there were demonic and
religious views that ran along side.
But in addition,
there were a series of
scientific challenges that in
a number of major shocks to
the system that slowly weakened
its hold and gave rise to doubters,
but did not thoroughly dismantle humor
realism until the late 19th century.
And even then,
it persists in popular culture and
some forms of alternative medicine.
What were some of these challenges?
I don't expect you to
remember these at this point.
We'll come back to them
later in their course,
but just so that you'll understand that
it wasn't as though this system never
had challenges.
Protestantism was a challenge with the
challenge to authority and established
text and Paracelsus whose dates are on
your handout was called the Martin Luther
of Madison, who rejected, um,
galenic and hippocratic medicine.
Altogether.
William Harvey discovered the circulation
of the blood that overthrew or
challenged Galen his anatomy
and his physiology, uh,
which were approved not to correspond to
the observed results of dissection and
pathology.
So the discovery of the circulation
of the blood was a major blow,
although oddly enough,
Harvey himself never rejected humoral.
Listen,
Hippocrates and Galen.
Then there was the scientific revolution
and in particular one can think of the
chemical revolution associated with men
like Joseph Priestley and Antoine Love
was they destroyed the
Aristotelian notion of elements.
Earth and air for example,
were found themselves to be composed of
a great number of modern elements that
go to make up what we know as the
periodic table and more generally the
scientific revolution mark to Democratic
turn from authority to empirical
evidence and it visioned scientific
and medical knowledge as infinitely
expandable and not bounded by set texts.
And then from the point
of view of our course,
the experience of epidemic
disease as we'll see,
made the idea of discretion improbable
as a mechanism needed to explain epidemic
disease because it's fairly flimsy as a
basis for explaining why so many people
and a single place at a single moment
of time had their echo lebree all
unbalanced at the same moment.
So the experience of epidemic disease
is important and we'll see the physician
for Daca,
Stuart came up with the idea of contagion
and many centuries ago and the 19th
century.
We'll see also with the development
of the idea of disease specificity.
And finally in the late 19th century,
the germ theory of disease,
which offers an entirely
different paradigm for disease.
So that's the journey will be taking to
the time when humor realism is replaced.
And we'll look at various embodiments,
uh,
along the way of what people
considered to be scientific medicine.
But here are a number of you will be
thinking that I've involved myself and an
important contradiction,
and you'll be thinking about a Asclepius
and the fact that I talked about
temples and uh, God,
uh, and in particular,
let's look at,
oh,
that's the God Asclepius and this is the,
uh, I'll talk about who he
is. Hippocrates and Galen,
we're both pious and
devout. Uh, that is to say,
although they believed in
a naturalistic medicine,
it wasn't that they didn't also believe
in the gods and prove the gods they
found in temple medicine what we might
call the world's first referral system.
Asclepius who was he?
He was first to moral hero who
became half human and half divine,
and then entirely a god.
He was thought to be the kindest of the
God's the one who loved humanity enough
to sacrifice himself for their sake.
His father was the god Apollo.
His daughters were interestingly named
the goddesses panacea and Hygieia and
physicians in the ancient world
might call themselves as sleepy ads,
meaning the sons of Asclepius who
regarded their father as a patron saint.
By the time of Alexander the Great Greece
possess three to 400 temples dedicated
to Asclepius,
Asclepius was said to have been killed
by Zeus because he taught mortals the art
of healing.
And Zeus feared that men and women would
compete with him and no longer being
subject to death,
but Asclepius never practiced magic.
He was merely the most skilled of
physicians using the same principles that
Asclepius ads like Hippocrates
and Galen would use as well.
Note,
of course there similarities to the story
of Christ and Asclepius was in fact a
major competitor with Christianity
for a number of centuries.
Unlike Christ after death,
he said to have risen and to be
present to eternally in the temples.
So the temples were shrines to
Asclepius at places like Athens.
I'll show you hope. A couple of
examples. That's cause where,
uh,
Hippocrates was from and this is,
these are the temple at Pergamum.
Um,
I just want to there, it's a whole,
this is more than just a temple,
although it is a temple. It's
a, almost a compound. Now,
the usefulness of identifying yourself
with Asclepius was that there was,
it's was provided positions
with the badge of identity,
a source of authority.
There were wandering peripatetic healers,
but now they're recognizable
as members of the same guild.
This gave them a collective presence
and authority and Asclepius also vouched
for their ethical conduct.
Remember,
these are peripatetic physicians
whom you invite into your home.
And so they needed to have someone vouch
for them and he vouches that there are
good doctors and that they have special
care for the poor who can't pay him.
But again, there is no contradiction
with naturalistic medicine.
The temples were precursors
in a way to health, spas,
Sanatoria or hospitals there they provided
care for the poor and the seriously
ill patients could enter them.
The precincts of these compounds after
a period of preparation in which they
bathed, fasted, prayed,
and offered sacrifice.
But the therapeutic strategy
comes to them in a particular way,
which is called an incubation,
which is to say that it night after the
prepared yourself carefully and the way
I just mentioned when you then the priest
will help you and when you fall asleep
at night,
you'll have a dream.
This is the incubation and
the God Asclepius will appear
to you and tell you the
throttle you pursued pursue
in order to become well again.
But the strategy was nothing other than
what a skilled physician would have
prescribed had he been skillfully
skillful and wise enough to have known.
There was never a retreatment prescribed
by Asclepius by magical means or a
miracles or by practices that weren't
accessible to the ordinary doctor.
So this is humoral medicine,
the first embodiment
of scientific medicine.
And I want us to look for the next several
sessions at the way in which it was
used as a lens to view the experience
of terrible epidemic catastrophes.
And we'll look also at the way in which
the experience of bluebonnet plague and
other epidemics challenged or raised
major questions about humoral theory and
helped propel the scientific medical
elite towards a different view of disease
and what it was.
So we'll see epidemics beginning
next time as a process.
And we'll also want then to explain it
and we'll look at bluebonnet plague as
the first of our major
epidemics in our course.